i had this rule with my old man and i  have it with my son which is when you're  fishing you can swear  and so we're out fishing he catches a  fish and i'm trying to get him to take a  picture with the fish before we let it  go and it flops out of his hands and and  these bass have these little spines on  on their back and the fin pokes them in  the hand falls in the water he starts to  cry  and he's like oh  and i said hey buddy are you all right  you all right he said oh  dad i'm about to swear  hey you know you know the rules and he  goes that bass that bass is stupid  because well you know i think we say hey  don't say someone call someone stupid  that's bad you shouldn't say that and i  s and he continues to christ  did you feel better he said a little bit  stupid stupid bass and i was like i was  like  all right buddy yeah you know now's the  time get it out and he goes  that stupid bass is a [ __ ] [ __ ]  [Applause]